black desert online is played by over 20
million people and those of us that play
it have been blown away with its unique
action mmo gameplay ever expanding
seamless open world with dynamic weather
its roster of two dozen playable classes
and a really compelling story but the
creators at pearl abyss are never
satisfied and they're taking black
desert online to a new level with its
free new eternal winter expansion with
cinematic and fully voiced quests an
enormous new snowy questing area full of
enemies to defeat and secrets to uncover
and the new draconia player class mmos
have never been this awesome and the
titular eternal winter that's not just
for show you'll have to keep yourself
warm in these icy lands or else you'll
catch frostbite fortunately you'll have
an adorable fox man named lando to help
guide you through all this and well
he'll make sure you know how to tackle
this strange new place how do you do
adventurer i am lando if you've never
played black desert online eternal
winter is the perfect entry point and
that's because you can start questing at
the mountain of eternal winter from
level one that's right you can jump into
a monster slaying crew with your friends
right after a brief tutorial and story
summary don't worry though if you want
to experience the full story of black
desert online you can choose to play at
the regular starting area no matter what
kind of black desert online player you
are the mountain of eternal winter will
have plenty for you to see and do during
your travels your journey will start at
eelton the local town where you can
stock up on supplies pick up quests and
take in the gorgeous scenery and if you
can't get enough of the sights there are
plenty of scenic viewpoints all over the
mountain you should check out and you
really should check them out because the
mountain is stunningly gorgeous you
don't want to miss out on video game
vistas like this when you do head out
into the world you'll have to contend
with more than just the rowdy
inhabitants of the land all that snowy
weather isn't just for show get caught
in a blizzard you'd better find some
place to warm up quick before the new
frostbite mechanic gets you and the
higher up the mountain you go the more
severe these storms will be but hey if
you do get caught in a particularly
strong blizzard you'll have a chance to
run into araborg and boy is she a good
time the developers at pearl abyss have
gone all out for eternal winter's story
with fully voiced cinematic cutscenes
and plenty of lore for the fans to sort
through as they adventure to the frigid
mountain summit and your guide in this
new area is none other than this fox
sherpa named lando nope not that lando
lando's both super cute and useful he's
a pretty great best friend to have in a
place like this this is the first time
we've had a character like this in black
desert online and it's a great new
addition to the game what do you mean
i'm just lazily ordering you around look
at all the stuff i'm carrying on my back
on top of the enormous amount of content
eternal winter is also introducing black
desert online's whopping 24th player
class draconia she's the antithesis to
the guardian class both of them
descended from ancient rival dragons and
she's got a personal connection to the
mountain of eternal winter draconia
carries a huge blood red blade named the
slayer but this ain't your daddy's great
sword the lightning-fueled slayer is
super quick and it comes with a bonus
dagger called the shard that will absorb
your foes energy when you stab them that
has gotta hurt with an arsenal like that
combined with her incredibly detailed
dragon armor the graceful draconia puts
the full power of marthanian on display
in every fight which is a very good
thing because you're gonna need all her
tricks to explore everything the
mountain of eternal winter has to offer
whether you're a veteran of black desert
online or just getting started the free
eternal winter expansion has so much for
you to do and explore but it's those
longtime players who will really
appreciate the work pearl abyss has put
in to enhance the black desert online
experience with this new expansion
they've truly outdone themselves with
this one we can already tell this
mountain is going to keep us busy for
years to come come on let's get this
show on the road